when the giants benched eli manning a
couple of years ago for geno smith it
did not go well for the giants or for
geno smith and eli manning was back
after a revolt from fans and former
players this time around probably not
going to happen eli manning is going to
have to stand there on the sideline he's
going to have to transition into the
role of backup quarterback so the
question becomes
will he accept that will he retire will
he ask to be traded to another team
could a team like the steelers embrace
an eli manning instead of the guy who
seems to be ready to go for them with
ben roethlisberger out for the season in
mason rudolph there's a lot of different
ways this can go
much of it depends upon how eli manning
reacts to the news that he is being sent
to the sideline and that this time it's
probably going to last a lot longer than
one week the ball is in his court and
the options are fairly simple eli
manning seems to be a guy who wants to
continue to play football but he doesn't
seem to be a guy who wants to play for a
team other than the giants then again
he's facing for the first time ever an
extended stretch where the giants don't
want him playing football for them that
could change his thinking and we'll see
how that plays out in the coming days
and weeks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports